考不到500分
选啥学校最吃香
说实话
大多数普通本科认可度低
就业还不如好专科
手上有门硬技术才是最稳的铁饭碗
20天讲透志愿填报的一切
今天框框一条视频带你深挖全国所有就业好
薪资高的宝藏
专科
先来看华北
北京推荐三所北京科技职业大学
这所学校很出名
药品生物集成电路
汽车工程都是王牌
跟亦庄经开区的企业合作
多毕业能够去国药奔驰
中兴这些大厂香得很
北京工业职业技术学院
原煤炭工业部直属的院校
机电测量专业口碑特别好
校园里还保留着矿山测量实训基地
就业率连续3年超过97%
北京信息职业技术学院
计算机通信是特色
跟联想中国电信有长期合作
很多学生没毕业就被预定了
天津推荐三所天津市职业大学
眼视光技术包装工程都是招牌
尤其眼视光专业全国知名
在医院和大型眼科机构中特别抢手
天津现代职业技术学院
不但是精密制造标杆院校
而且王牌专业无人机应用技术全国首创
药品和食品也很有特色
天津医学高等专科学校
护理康复药学很强
跟医大总医院肿瘤医院有实习直通对口专业
七成毕业生进了医疗单位
河北我推荐两所河北工业职业技术大学
冶金材料是看家本领
钢铁智能冶金技术全国第一
实训用的是钢厂真设备
缩小版
保五和刚来这定点招聘
河北科技工程职业技术大学位于河北邢台
汽车类和机械机电式天花板
依托河北制造基础
对接河钢
中建长城汽车重点专业
国企家体制内就业率超过六成
山西也有两所山西机电职业技术学院
至山西装备制造王牌院校
数控技术是国家双高牵头专业
机电实力拔尖
山西工程职业学院原冶金部直属冶金技术
煤矿开采都是顶尖
想进山西焦煤钛钢这类重工业央企的
可以重点看
来到东北
辽宁推荐两所辽宁省交通高等专科学校
依托辽宁基建汽车产业集群
道路桥梁
汽车运用与维修是强项
跟辽宁交头
华晨宝马合作毕业生进省高速地铁路桥公色多
渤海船舶职业学院
背靠葫芦岛船舶工业基地
船舶工程技术全国有名
跟北京大连沈阳建立了多个就业基地
四五成学生进了船厂
接下来是吉林长春汽车职业技术大学
新能源汽车智能网联
顶尖是和一汽共建的汽车职校
就业
能直接去一汽红旗
奥迪大众生产线做技师或者班组长
然后我们来看华东上海
推荐三所上海民航职业技术学院
民航局直属飞机制造与维修
顶尖和中国商飞
东航有订单班
搞飞机维修很对口
上海工艺美术职业学院扎根上海
文创时尚产业
工艺美术品设计
全国有名
上海各大文创设计企业常年校招
想搞手工艺的
可以看看上海电子信息职业技术学院
牵头成立长三角电子信息职教集团
通信技术专业对标华为认证体系
搞通信芯片封测的动手能力很硬核
再来看江苏无锡职业技术大学
数控物联网实力超强
跟无锡周边500多家公司有合作
长三角制造企业抢着要
南京工业职业技术大学
这是黄炎培1918年创立的
全国首家公办职业本科机电电气术王牌毕业生
九成进制造企业
南京信息职业技术学院
原电子工业部直属通信电子专业很硬
跟华为中兴南京熊猫有合作
大把校友在江苏的通信运营商it企业
常州信息职业技术学院软件技术专业群
拿过国家级教学成果一等奖
信息安全也不差
浙江推荐四所浙江机电职业技术大学
机械智能控制是强项
把德国双元制本土化做得很彻底
智能制造实训基地直接照搬工厂标准
按工程师的路子进行培养
学生动手能力很强
杭州职业技术大学
电梯工程服装设计师特色学校
最近有电梯实训塔教学
就像在真的电梯井里干活
金华职业技术大学
国内顶尖的职业类院校
机械护理
这些招牌都很硬
有八成毕生留在浙江发展
宁波职业技术大学
建在保税区里的大学
学生能够进中外合资企业跟岗实习
国际化视野在高职里面很少见
模具设计制造
化工实力拔尖
安徽有两所芜湖职业技术大学
机械新能源汽车食品都很强
奇瑞海螺常年定点招人
安徽机电职业技术学院
曾经是机械工业部直管工业机器人
是国家A档双高专业
多次拿过全国职业院校技能大赛一等奖
福建呢也推荐两所福建信息职业技术学院
依托福建软件园产业
互联网电气都不差
学校和福建本地it企业合作实习机会很多
福建船政交通职业学院
百年船政名校
航海道桥
全国知名
中原海运
福州地铁航运轨道交通国企每年大批量招人
江西也有两所
江西应用职业技术学院
国土资源调查社王牌宝石鉴定全国前三
而且还是攀岩名校
培养出好几位世界冠军
还有江西职业技术大学
原九江船舶工业学校
隶属中船总公司
有仿真的船舶工程实训中心
毕业生进江南造船
沪东中华的比例很高
接下来是山东有三所山东商业职业技术学院
鲁商集团直管的商科名校
市场营销云计算是强项
日照职业技术大学
水产养殖技术专业全国排名前三
效力团队
把虾青素提炼纯度
提高到了国际同行业标准水平的4.5倍
成果等20多家企业应用淄博职业技术大学
新能源汽车电气护理实力强劲
和海尔海信
上汽通用有深度合作
鲁中地区制造医疗商贸行业很喜欢本校学生
再来看华中和华南
河南有两所黄河水利职业技术大学
全国水利行业第一所公办职业本科
办学初心就是治黄核心水利
水利测绘这块堪称国家队
河南工业职业技术大学
原兵器工业部直属智能制造数控技术服务军工
常年为玉溪军工集团中航光电定向培养
背景够硬
湖北推荐两所武汉船舶职业技术学院
我国首批国防军工院校之一
主打桑海义工
海防安全
海河运输
海洋开发新型工业化
在中船集团和大型装备制造企业认可度很高
武汉职业技术大学
在2001年首创全国高职订单班培养模式
跟华为华星光电
长江存储深度绑定
光电技术全国知名
湖南推荐三所
湖南工业职业技术学院
王牌是数控和电器
湖湘工匠一堆
在中联重科三一重工的车间里
这里毕业的特别多
长沙民政职业技术学院
把生老病养葬全生命周期做成了专业群
殡葬养老专业全国排第一
民生服务领域没有对手
长沙航空职业技术学院
空军装备部直属飞机维修
导弹维修是顶流
校内停着真飞机工教学
广东呢有四所
深圳职业技术大学职业学校
天花板通信电子信息
超强研发的工业软件
给企业创造了近20亿效益
说是高职理的9851点不夸张
广东轻工职业技术大学
华南轻工老牌名校
艺术设计和轻化工是看家本领
珠三角轻工行业遍地是校友
广州职业技术大学
背靠番禺珠宝商贸产业集群
珠宝专业极具特色
新能源汽车艺术设计也很强
深圳信息职业技术大学
软件通信都是强项
和华为腾讯共建产业学院
大湾区互联网芯片企业
每年都放出大量的校招名额
接下来看西部省份
重庆有两所
重庆电子科技职业大学
芯片制造
工业互联网顶尖
是电子信息领域的尖子生
跟华为长安汽车合办的产业学院
在西南地区信息技术行业影响力很强
重庆工业职业技术大学
模具设计与制造专业是全国的标杆
有国家级装备制造虚拟仿真中心
经常承办国家模具数字化设计与制造大赛
然后到四川成都航空职业技术大学
原航空工业部直属的歼二零
运二零背后都有这所学校的影子
跟成飞歼击机生产线深度合作
是搞航空制造的人才摇篮
四川交通职业技术学院
道桥隧道专业在西南地区数一数二
很多毕业生直接进蜀道集团
中铁系统
陕西推荐两所陕西工业职业技术大学
工科底子扎实
电气机械都不差
在陕西装备制造业里面
技术骨干很多都是从这出来的
西安航空职业技术学院地处阎良中国航空城
跟西非试飞院门对门
学飞机维修
无人机应用的学生
能在国产大飞机生产线上实习
最后啊必须要重点提一下
不愁就业的铁路电力警校和司法警校
铁路就看这些学校
原来很多隶属于铁道部
跟各铁路局有定向培养好进铁路系统
电力呢景这几所都是各地进国家电网
南方电网的重点专科院校
警校和司法警校分别推荐这些对口专业
能走公安联考超路或者便捷入警渠道
入编比例很高
比一般考公友好太多了
如果进了其中一所
拿个铁饭碗不是啥难事儿
OK如果这期视频对你有帮助的话
别忘了点赞收藏加关注哦
我是风光
下期视频再见